debate club first up is Reuben
from London Reuben from what oh that is
me I maybe that's your English brother
over there dude and let's just like me
you guys look pretty similar oh it's my
mom I was mom I'm not a bull Todd he
shaves it a little extra on the sides
though that guy straight Trilly Eliot
right there that dudes trill as hell bro
um so he's saying after a night out with
a random girl your place are her place
God usually her place so I can skip the
[ __ ] out you know I'm saying she's at
yours then I come up with let's say just
it's a one-night hookup you know come up
with a line why she needs to leave like
you feel bad about yourself that her
place I do not get up early I'm out go
home take a [ __ ] I can never saw will
never sleep at someone's place or I'll
let them sleep at my place so I'm not
gonna ever probably be married a problem
with it oh I can't do it you never stay
the night over any of your friends house
growing up yeah David I'll wet the bed
all the time and then I have to get up
in the middle of the night Oh neat
around in the dark and find their washer
dryer oh my god dude one time couldn't
find the dryer I had to clean the sheet
and then they had like a lamp and I had
to like hold the sheet really close to
the bulb for like two hours and just
move it or mostly it would dry what I
would do to heat off the light bulb but
I don't know what if I stay at a
friend's house and I pissed I was also a
Pete if I'd piss the bed as a kid yeah
or leaked out of your brain you want
either/or but if I was leaking my piss
at a friend's house what I'd do I bet
God [ __ ] I wet the bed I'd get up get a
big glass of water and pretend I drop
the water everywhere
everybody please a drink well the
president kid I thought I did I was four
you [ __ ] but as a kid you like oh they
don't know but they just played along
with it now that I'm older they
definitely know they know definitely
know like Oh Brenda's drinking a yellow
water again what a crazy guy huh so like
pee pee ah definitely staying at their
place though but going to their places
it's neat to see what's going on you
know immediately different smells
yeah what their vibe is you know real
dirty oh yeah oh dude I'm recording this
girl's place one time it was disgusting
bro and I was like oh but you put up
with some [ __ ] but I rode used to hook
up with some girl really in a room eyes
again I like roaches really she was that
hot I'm actually like roaches like that
do you mind my son not at all Wow yeah
then I throw it down with your disgust
and I'm out of here oh god what an
[ __ ] I would stay and help clean the
place up
you wouldn't do [ __ ] would do [ __ ]
whatever help them clean it up to their
house but we'd let you in the [ __ ]
house bro you're dressed like that but
you dress like a black like a backup
catcher from league of their own today
we are members of the All American
League we come I say there I say there
their house yeah 62% of people say at
her place and yeah it's a fun like kind
of game to play what's going on with us
steel
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching